good morning it's Tuesday I recently got
to wondering when the median human being
was born and in researching that
question I learned something interesting
and surprising but let's start with that
hypothetical median person so obviously
we don't have like super firm statistics
on how many people have ever lived or
when they died or any of that but
through a mix of population modeling and
genetic research our best current guess
is that about 117 billion modern humans
as we are known have ever lived so I was
trying to figure out when did the person
in the middle of that 117 billion live
the uh I'm bad at math 58.5 billionth
person now I probably would have guessed
like 1900 1750 something like that
because there are way more humans than
there used to be I mean fewer humans
lived on earth six thousand years ago
than currently live in Mexico City seven
percent of the people who've ever lived
are currently alive so the median human
can't be that far removed from us right
except no that's wrong at least
according to the population reference
Bureau the 58.5 billion person probably
was born sometime between 10 and 100 CE
so about 2 000 years ago that is to say
of all the people who've been born most
were born and died before the Roman
Emperor Nero or the Malian Emperor Mansa
Musa they lived and died before the idea
of minutes and seconds before guns
before the emergence of Christianity and
Islam AS Global forces and before
potatoes or pineapples were in
afro-eurasia this median person almost
certainly could not read or write they
probably did not believe in one God and
if they survived to adulthood which they
probably didn't they were probably
farmers and probably had many children
some of whom almost definitely died now
when I was young I was taught that in
the old days the old days were never
quite defined life expectancy was 30
which I took to mean that the average
adult died at 30 and that's not the case
at least in Sweden where we have
relatively good data if you live to be
10 in the early 1800s your life
expectancy was around 46. and in 1841
England if you to be 20 your life
expectancy was around 60. it's just that
overall life expectancy was brought down
to below 30 because child mortality was
so high these days one sometimes hears
that the only reason life expectancy has
gone up is because child mortality has
gone down and that's also not the case
in 1865 Italy even if you survived
childbirth your life expectancy was
under 50 today it's well over 70. like
it's worth remembering that 200 years
ago about a quarter of all humans died
of tuberculosis and most of them died
under 40. also girls who survived
childhood had a very high chance of
dying in childbirth in some communities
over 10 percent that said child
mortality was very very high like in
1800 about 30 percent of people born in
France died before the age of 10 but it
used to be even higher like in Iron Age
France life expectancy wasn't 28 or 30
it was 10 or 12. our best current
guesses is that when the median person
was born 2 000 years ago half of all
people died before the age of 10. child
mortality was so high that birth rates
were 5 times greater than they are now
but the overall population of humans
barely increased and this is why the
median human was born two thousand years
ago not because there were so many
people back then but because there were
so many people who died young early
death wasn't common the way that dying
at say 65 is now it was the norm the way
dying at 80 is now I mean even last year
more people died before the age of five
than died between 65 and 69. so it's
likely that even today most of the 110
billion humans who've died never saw the
age of 20. we can't do anything about
historical rates of premature death of
course but we can choose to live in a
world where fewer people die early I
know we can make that choice because we
have made it before that's what we're
trying to do at pih.org Hank and John
and through silly things like pizza Miss
which by the way raised over a hundred
thirty thousand dollars toward better
maternal and child health care in
impoverished communities thank you Hank
I'll see you on Friday